so now we're going to get to the second
interview that trump did in the last
couple of days
this one was with total pro-trump
sycophant maria bartoromo of fox news
and fox business fame i've talked before
you know when i was starting to get into
following the stock market and learning
about uh
that type of thing and personal finance
etc maria bartiromo was really a
groundbreaking reporter on cnbc uh first
woman to report from the floor of the
new york stock exchange and she would do
good interviews with ceos and ask real
questions somehow now she's just a trump
brown-noser spreading conspiracy
theories and screaming um
and the theme of this interview
is really revisionist history
here is donald trump claiming covid was
over when i left office now that's not
true you might you might remember that's
that wasn't true but let's listen same
time some people don't want to take it
and you know when i was president you
didn't have this problem with people not
wanting to take it they don't take it
because they don't trust biden and they
don't trust the biden administration now
let's add some reality to this issue
when donald trump left office
900 000 people a day were getting
vaccines
it was almost exclusively health care
workers and the oldest and most health
compromised
nobody was really in a position of
deciding whether or not to get the
vaccine because there were almost no
vaccines available when donald trump
left office when i was president you
didn't have people protesting the
vaccine
because there was no vaccine to get just
think back everybody wanted to get it
and we were given out over a million
shots a day now trump's lying about a
million a day it was nine hundred
thousand overstating it by more than ten
percent but also the issue there about
people people weren't protesting and
everybody wanted to get it people
weren't protesting because there weren't
yet enough vaccines available for it to
be a thing and number two it's not true
everyone wanted to get it in fact
more people when trump left office said
i'm never getting the vaccine the number
of anti-vaxxers has declined since trump
left office everything he's saying here
is a lie we had that thing rocking and
he's now president and he's doing a
lousy job at coronavirus they
coronavirus is back if that ever
happened to me where it came back okay
when i left it was all virtually gone it
was over it was a path now that's a lie
the last day trump was in office more
than 4
000 people died of covid
we now were back up to about a thousand
a day dying of covet it's a disaster
it's a tragedy and much of it is because
of anti-vaxxerism how was it over when
more than 4 000 people died on the day
trump left office now it's coming back
through the delta
and i don't know if you even want to
call it that all you call it is the
china virus is back
and so why is he doing a good job he did
a bad job with sars the h1n1 very bad
job remember that the
obama biden had two-thirds approval
on uh on on on the h1n1 joke of a job a
horrible job all of a sudden they said
oh he's doing so well and remember h1n1
was essentially no more serious than the
flu like we stopped testing for it once
we realized that okay so trump totally
incoherent there then
trump says uh communism it's communism
what is communism editorial decisions
are communism stolen from him and he's
yes i know the tape
yeah they can blackmail him stolen by a
russian he was sitting there with some
woman i don't know who the hell the
woman and she didn't have clothes on and
neither did he
this would have been five years ago ten
years ago the biggest scandal in history
and now they don't they don't put it on
i'm telling you this is communism what
they do is they don't put things on not
airing a story is communism guys don't
you understand in fact last week i was
on vacation i didn't air a story about
afghanistan because i wasn't here
that was communism yeah
it's if like if something's bad about
biden they don't put it on if
something's bad about me they make it
ten times worse than they put it on if
something's good about me well we know
that's right yeah we know that's right
maria we are very important analysis
there then trump suggests without any
evidence
that we don't really need booster shots
i told you at the top of the show that
the fda is now saying uh basically at
the eight month mark from receiving your
second cover dose you should get a third
dose that's going to start very soon um
trump downplays that and he's like yeah
it's just money-making for uh pfizer
it's a great point it's a
but i still come back to the idea i
still come back to the idea of a booster
shot i mean yes you're right the back
seams
that sounds you know what that sounds to
me like a money-making operation for
pfizer
okay think of the money involved
tens of billions of dollars how good of
business is that if you're a pure
businessman
you say you know what let's give them
another shot that's another 10 billion
dollars
insanely insanely dangerous comment
money coming in the whole thing is just
crazy it doesn't
you wouldn't think you would need a
booster you know when these first came
out they were good for life
then they were good for a year or two
and i could see the writing on the wall
i could see the dollar signs in their
eyes of that guy that runs spicer now of
course there's so many deceptions there
first of all dollar signs in the eyes of
the guy who runs pfizer trump
hand-picked pfizer as the company that
he was going to pre-purchase vaccines
from in his big heroic vaccine delivery
is trump saying that his judgment is so
bad
that he did business with a prophet
monger that is that is pfizer and of
course the entire thing about the the
duration of uh the vaccine a lot of
what's going on is that the virus is
changing the vaccine was tailored to
what was out there when the vaccine was
made
and at this point that's what over a
year ago that that was formulated
um and the virus is changing so the
decrease decreased efficacy is of course
against against delta it's just all
crazy and people hear this stuff and
they believe it which is the really
dangerous thing
um okay uh last thing here
this is trump just saying things uh he
he seems to be saying he kind of like
indirectly threatened chinese president
xi it's very weird it's very bad you
know i had a great relationship with
president xi as good as anybody's ever
had
uh really a good relationship i spent a
lot of time with him yeah i was over
there he toured me china and places that
he toured him we're incredible actually
and i said it would be a terrible thing
if we ever fought be a terrible thing if
these beautiful places were ever blown
up
[Laughter]
be terrible if uh your entire country
here was blown up one day president xi
let's uh let's make sure that doesn't
happen
what a bizarre series of interviews and
the real question is what is the point
of all this what is trump building
towards clearly reappearing in advance
of his rally in alabama saturday night
which we'll be covering live
what is happening here what is trump
building towards let me know your
thoughts and we'll be right back
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort that i expect from these guys
and all form is one of our sponsors
today they're giving you twenty percent
off at allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now my favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's solidly built it's huge
it's roomy it has a modern minimalist
design which i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room their
prices are very reasonable and when you
get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty stop buying poorly made
furniture go to customize your own all
form sofa or chair right now and get 20
off your entire order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman i've also put the link right
underneath this video